So the first question we need to answer for any problem is what are the inputs?
For this problem their fairly clearly stated says, given your birthday and the
current date. Well, that's the input to the problem. What's the set of inputs we
really want this to work for? Should it really just work for my birthday and
today's current date? If that's all we wanted it to work for then we can figure
this out once. We don't actually have to write a procedure. So I think what is
intended by this is something much more general. So the inputs are really two
dates, and that gives us the type of the input, that gives us a set of all
possible inputs. We need to think a little more carefully to know if they're all
valid. Well, the statement of the question give us a good clue here. It said,
assume that the birthday and the current data are correct dates and no time
travel. This probably is a valid assumption if we're talking about birthdays and
current dates. If we're comparing any two dates, well this says that the second
date needs to be after the first one. Assumptions like this make life easier for
programmers. That means it's easier to write our code since it has to work for
fewer possible inputs. I like the way Mattias stated this is no time travel. For
a program specification, we probably want to be a little more precise, and just
state simply the second date must not be before the first date. And if we're
being good defensive programmers, we should check if this is true. It's an
assumption, it's up to the user of our code to satisfy this, because we've said,
well that's a requirement. To use our solution you have to make sure the second
date is not before the first date. But if we're going to be smart we're going to
program in a more defensive way, because sometimes other people might make
mistakes or we might make mistakes. And we're actually going to check this in
our code. The other assumption we might want is something about the range of
dates. Calendars are very complicated and they've changed over history. We're
going to require that the dates are valid dates in the Gregorian calendar, which
started in October 1582. Our code will probably work for dates outside this
range, but it might not get exactly the right answer, since when the calendar
changed, the meaning of dates changed.